some news from germany now and
chancellor olaf schultz has held his
first summer press conference continuing
the tradition of his predecessor angela
merkel
schultz answered questions on some of
the most pressing domestic and foreign
policy issues such as the war in ukraine
the rising cost of living and germany's
dependence on russia for gas that's
something the government is trying to
get on top of before the colder winter
months
dw also asked the chancellor about the
possibility of introducing a travel ban
for all russians schultz said he has a
very hard time with the idea and said
such a ban could undermine other
measures being taken against russia
we have discussed very extensive
sanctions which affect many specific
individuals and oligarchs and supporters
of russia's most powerful circles and we
will certainly continue to do so
it would rather weaken the effectiveness
of these measures if the winner directed
against everyone including completely
innocent people
so let's bring in our political
correspondent nina
nina to get us started why is this topic
on the agenda now
well our colleague asked this question
because schweitzer's counterparts in
estonia and in finland have raised this
topic they say it's not okay that
ordinary russians are still going on
holiday in europe in light of russia's
aggression against ukraine and olaf
schultz said a very clear answer to this
question he says sanctions must be
targeted and it will have to target the
powerful circles in moscow and there
cannot be a blanket ban on all russians
traveling to europe because that would
be contradictory the hope here in berlin
even if not voiced publicly is still
that the russian population will one day
direct their anger at the government in
moscow themselves but of course since
estonia and finland are eu countries
this is a topic that will be addressed
by the foreign ministers at their next
eu meetings later this month
now in germany in recent months the
government has repeatedly said that it
is fearing social unrest due to rising
energy costs and inflation did we hear
chancellor schultz replete repeat those
concerns today
no on the contrary but of course there
are estimates
that say that an ordinary german family
may have to pay an additional 1000 euros
a year for energy this year and this is
of course a lot there are lots of people
who get by on what they earn but they
don't necessarily have any savings and
so many people also from all of
charlotte's government have said that if
nothing is done then there could be
social unrest here once people are faced
with their energy bills so olaf charles
was sitting here trying to de outline in
detail again what the government is
actually doing to help people get
through this crisis and he did sound
very confident he said that the
government is doing two things use
maximum speed to win germany off russian
energy supplies but of course those
things take time which is why also the
government has already invested 30
billion euros in financial aid for
germans and that more money will come
tax relief will come also the social
welfare system will be reformed so that
people are not alone which is why
charlotte sounded so confident that
there will not be any social unrest this
year let's listen to what he had to say
no i do not believe that there will be
unrest in this country
in the way that has been outlined
and that is because germany is a welfare
state
former chancellor helmut schmidt once
described this as one of the greatest
achievements of german politics
and this welfare state must be effective
in this situation by clearly saying that
we will not leave anyone behind
i deliberately use the expression you
will not walk alone into the future
and that is also true that's what our
response to this is and that's why i'm
quite confident
well at the moment of course it's warm
in berlin so nobody needs to heat their
houses and whether or not charlotte's
prediction will hold true that there
will not be any social unrest we'll
probably only find out once people are
really faced with those higher energy
bills once it gets colder here
all right dw political correspondent
nina haza thanks so much for that update
you